Senate Republicans health care bill
faces a critical test this week there is
supposed to be a vote before Congress
goes on its fourth of July recess but
the newest Obamacare replacement does
not have enough support five of the 52
GOP senators say they oppose the current
bill Republican leaders leaders need
three of those votes to pass it because
all of the Democrats plan to vote no
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning it is a
struggle Margaret because beyond those
five Republican senators who have
already said that they're voting no
there are others who say that they have
serious concerns and still more who are
getting an earful from Democratic and
Republican governors who worry about
what this bill will mean for their
states I want to see a bill at home on
Sunday the president expressed
confidence that GOP leaders will be able
to adjust the Senate bill to win over
holdouts Healthcare is a very
complicated subject from the standpoint
that you move it this way and this group
doesn't like it you move it a little bit
over here you have a very narrow path
moderate Republicans are balking at the
bills restrictions on federal funding
for Medicaid cuts being downplayed by
the White House enjoying them cuts but
we don't we don't see them as cuts it's
slowing the rate of growth in the future
and getting Medicaid back to where was I
have very serious concerns about the
bill Maynes
Susan Collins and Nevada's Dean Heller
argued their states can't make up for
the reduction in Medicaid funding in
Nevada alone more than 200,000 people
gained coverage under Obamacare zhh
Medicaid expansion I'm telling you right
now I cannot support a piece of
legislation that takes insurance away
from tens of millions of Americans and
hundreds of thousands of Nevadans but
some conservative senators argue the
bill doesn't cut enough because it
retains a good chunk of Obama cares tax
credits to help people buy insurance
realize that the Obama care subsidies in
this bill are actually greater under the
Republican bill than they are under the
current Obamacare law that is not
anywhere close to repeal he's one of
several Republicans who say the process
is moving too fast there's no way we
should be voting on this next week no
way I don't know quite why the rush I
frankly would like more days to consider
this
Pennsylvania's Pat Twomey who helped
write the bill says waiting won't make
things better but I see this bill as a
first step a first important step in the
direction of repealing those portions of
Obamacare that we can in the absence of
much support from the medical community
GOP leaders are hoping for a decent
review from the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office the CBO has
been crunching the numbers in this bill
and should release its analysis as early
as today Gail all right Thank You Nancy